the Netherlands are
leading
compe GL
is
ah je pas
c'est un peu trop de pression je pense
et j'ai pas sugéré le
stress qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour
que c'est quelque chose que tu sais
faire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé avant de rentrer sur le dans dans
le sty qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on c'était quoi les
consignes tout
simplement mon job faire exactement
comme comme je sais
faire mouvement normal quoi après je
pense
que tout ce qui est extérieur fait
que ça va ça pas
marcher tu peux pas enlever les choses
qui sont à l'extérieur ben non c'est
pour ça qu'il faut que
je faut que je travaille avec ça faut
que c'est de l'expérience
et mant faut travailler on va essayer de
mettre en chose des choses en place pour
pour que ça se reproduise plus et que
j'arrive plus sereine et et que ça
marche comme comme je le veux une étape
tu avais dit hier non ouais la route est
longue péter
vasy